Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are... Moco-chan, why are you laughing?
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
And today, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you for joining us for today, the 85th episode of FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
And it's officially the first episode of FUWAMOCO Morning with FUWAMOCO and our new dog!
It's been a while!
It's been a while.
Ruffians, were you able to wake up okay?
You know, it's the first FUWAMOCO Morning since
The end of February?
It's nice this year again!
Bright and early!
You sleeping?
You're awake!
You're awake now!
FUWAMOCO Morning is back!
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Ah, I see some Ruffians!
I see some new Ruffians?
I don't know.
I think some Ruffians are still feeling a bit sleepy.
But I think...
I'm feeling sleepy too.
Hi, I'm Moco-chan!
My eyes get very open!
Well, for Ruffians that are maybe this is your first FUWAMOCO Morning, and for maybe Ruffians who are half asleep and kind of forgot... Like me!
To explain, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short, full-out morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
AKA FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Moco-chan, you can say that right now.
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Big Ruffians!
You know, you know that there's been a lot going on in FUWAMOCO's world recently.
And I'm sure yours too, right?
Right!
A lot of things, you know, busy busy.
But with FUWAMOCO, we haven't really had too much time to think about things that, like, immediately going on!
Right!
That's right in our face!
Yeah, but...
You know, I think maybe you've been wondering.
I've seen a couple comments here and there.
Yeah.
You know.
Where is Pero?
You know, I've got some questions from you.
Yeah.
Well, Ruffians!
It looks like you can breathe a sigh of relief!
That's good!
Yeah, because I'm Ruffian this year!
Oh my god!
Recently!
Okay.
Let's see where we spotted.
Usually we're not that excited, but... Let's see!
It's rare!
Has Pero been on vacation?
Wow!
Oh...
Did you get a virus on your phone?
That's pretty impressive.
I guess Pero's taking over.
I wonder what he's planning.
Why would Pero want to control your smartphone?
I don't know if you think about it.
You know, our smartphones are a key part of our daily life, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, it's hard to do some things without it, so... You know, if Heretics control the phone... Controls the person.
Wait, huh?
What's he planning?
Is he planning to take control of every Ruffian?
Huh?
Is he planning... World domination?
I thought that was our plan.
Well, I'm sure he's not planning to do something as sinister as that.
But he is Pero after all.
Yeah.
Well, I guess you never know, huh?
Yeah, maybe.
Do you think he'll at least order us some Ponder Wings as a housewarming gift?
That would be nice!
Not that we haven't had a bunch of pon-de-rings already, but... BAU BAU!
More pon-de-rings is always good.
Oh, thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
I think there might be some Ruffians!
You know, but, well, you know, your life is busy.
That's why we're so happy to be a part of your morning like this with FUWAMOCO Morning!
But just in case you know you've been extra extra extra busy and kind of wondering where is FUWAMOCO, you know?
We know there's lots of you, so don't feel silly, okay?
Well, for the past month or so, we've actually been in Japan moving into our new doghouse!
We did it, Ruffians!
Doghouse!
A new chapter to FUWAMOCO's journey has officially begun!
It was a little bit of a ruff move, a really ruff move.
Just a bit.
Kaori-senpai!
Good piece!
BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Well, you know, now in our new throne house, we're in Japan.
I was just so incredibly happy to be back here with you.
We're really looking forward to, you know, sharing a lot of silly moments together.
Ah, thank you Gally-senpai!
BAU BAU!
And you know, not just silly moments, but you know, hopefully we can share a lot more about what it's like living in Japan as Demon Guide Dogs.
Of course, we're still kind of getting used to a lot of things, but we sure will have lots of interesting stories to share.
Some that only FUWAMOCO could have!
Right?
Yeah, there's already been lots of silly mishaps, but please look forward to our new adventures!
And you know, not just new adventures, but we know a lot of Ruffians are wondering, why?
That means FUWAMOCO Morning!
It's midnight, FUWAMOCO.
That's gonna be hard on them.
What about their other stream time?
But actually, this schedule is way better for us!
It is.
We can actually get a proper sleep, you know?
Sleep?
Not such a day, guys!
Not 3 to 4 hours, but a full sleep.
You know, FUWAMOCO, we're long sleepers!
We're not good with naps.
We need a full rest.
Yeah, I know.
And now we can do that!
And still have just as much fun if not more.
Yeah, but like we said before, you know, we're the same dogs.
But, you know, now we just have new digs.
And we're not in the Northwest Passage anymore, we're in Japan!
But other than that...
Same, FUWAMOCO.
Same.
And you know we hope that this move will help us be able to grow ourselves as demon guard dogs and allow us to try out a bunch of new exciting things to help protect your smile.
We'll continue to do our best!
Yeah!
Okay, more fans!
Thank you!
I can still wink.
BAU BAU!
Lots of exciting things going on, but yesterday was also very exciting because it was the birthday of Advent Shining Gem Koseki Bijou!
Biboo's birthday!
She had a slumber party together with all the pebbles and all of us too!
It was a bunch of fun, right, Ruffians?
Yeah!
Right.
Yeah, you know, we watched a movie that she went to watch called Space Jam.
Space Jam.
And it was about basketball!
Which was fun.
Fun.
Basketball.
Right.
And Nerissa, she said that there was a cute girl, but
I don't know.
I only saw one.
I saw a bunny.
There was a bunny lady.
Maybe she was there for 30 seconds.
Yeah.
A minute, maybe.
I don't know.
Bunny lady.
I feel like Pekora-senpai is much cuter.
I didn't really feel much, honestly.
BAU.
Love you.
Moco-chan.
Who's cuter, Kai?
Oh, it's this time of day!
Pekora-senpai.
Pekora-senpai's the cutest!
How ruff he is?
But Pekora-senpai's our sister, right?
She's our sister then.
She's cute.
Fuwawa's the cutest!
BAU BAU!
Hi!
It's me, Moco!
Who is it?
You're the cutest!
Hi!
It's you who's the cutest!
Oh.
Fuwawocutest.
BAU BAU!
Hi.
Mococute!
I saw Mococute!
I searched for a while but I didn't see a Mococute!
Moco-chan!
Why?
I think that means you're cute.
But, after that, we played jackpot games together, which was really fun.
We designed t-shirts.
T-shirts, yeah.
They're kind of really silly.
But, you can even order your own shirt if you want something sort of scribble-like.
Like that.
Yeah, I made a...
Fuwawa shirt.
I'm sorry, Moco-chan.
I didn't have time to draw you.
It says BAU BAU and I look very, uh... I was the designer.
Oh, you designed it?
Yes.
Oh!
Team effort!
Also, it is a FUWAMOCO shirt.
But more importantly!
Biboo's birthday merch!
It's super cute, just like Biboo.
Maybe not as cute as...
No, it's pretty cute.
You know, Biboo in her pajamas.
Yeah!
A bunch of plushies.
Very cute.
And she has a tapestry.
Who wouldn't want a tapestry?
Right.
You know, proudly display, you know, on the walls.
Maybe right above your bed.
It's cute.
Right?
You can say goodnight, Biboo.
But!
Sleepy.
Say sweet dreams to FUWAMOCO!
Biboo also has a squishy Pebble Pushy.
Pebble Pushy!
It's just fun.
Yeah, but I was a bit surprised though, because you know, Biboo's always saying she's rock hard, right?
Right!
But apparently pebbles, pebbles are squishy.
You learn new stuff, huh?
Well, I guess you can find out just how squishy they are if you get your own!
Yeah!
But Biboo also has a super cute mug bag!
I'm pretty sure she designed herself too, she drew it!
Ruffians, you know I love mugs!
And of course I won't watch you!
Yeah, but you know we don't have really mugs.
We don't!
It's the perfect time!
But what will the mug situation be once it gets into our paws?
Why did I say that?
I should have been quiet.
Yeah, hopefully the mug is hard.
That would be hard to drink out of a soft mug.
The squishy mug.
Although that could be fun.
It could be fun.
Fluffy mug.
Fuzzy mug.
Maybe hide the wash.
Maybe waterproof fluff and fuzz.
Single use.
Single use!
BAU BAU!
You can place a pre-order for her birthday merch now on the official hololive shop, so please go check it out!
And get your paws on Biboo's first birthday merch ever!
BAU BAU!
Fluffy fuzz in your mouth!
I guess that's the downside of a fluffy and fuzzy mug, huh?
Not moldy.
Fluffy and fuzzy.
You could put it on the handle.
The handle.
Right.
Handle?
You shouldn't be touching the handle to your mouth when you're drinking out of a mug, right?
I'm confused.
Mugs have handles, Moco-chan!
Yeah, that's technically a handle.
Why do I want to confuse Ruffians?
BAU BAU!
Yeah, Moco-chan gets confused a lot.
Which makes us susceptible.
You know, when you just moved to a new country, it's kind of hard to get adjusted, right?
It takes a little bit of time.
You know, because there's still a lot of things you don't know about.
Uh, yeah.
Yeah.
Well, we already got scammed.
And yep, it was Moco-chan.
It's all your fault, Moco-chan.
It's not!
Yeah, before it could stop things from happening, she had already swept her carton.
And yeah, Moco-chan was coerced into buying some cheesecake.
I have my reasons, okay?
It was because it was raining really hard all of a sudden.
We had time, we needed to wait somewhere.
I didn't want to wait in the rain.
And then this nice lady calls out and goes, Oh, would you like to stay out of the rain and have some cheesecake?
And I go, Oh, that sounds good.
I have time for cheesecake.
I have time out of the rain.
And so she said, Oh, well, here's some cheesecake.
It's very fancy.
And usually it's 2,000 yen, but for today only.
2,000 yen per slice?
That's like $20.
Today it's like...
$1500 yen, so that's like $15 each per slice.
And I thought, wow, that's an expensive cheesecake.
But I mean, we get to stay out of the rain, so it's okay.
I guess we'll get one.
She was like, do you want two?
There's two of you.
And I said, no, we can share.
It's okay.
At first Moco-chan was like, oh, money-chan!
We can get money-chan a piece.
I have to think about money-chan.
So I was thinking about if we should get money-chan a piece.
And then I was trying to phone money-chan because that's what Moco-chan said I should do.
I said to phone.
I needed to make decisions.
And I decided to just get one piece, and then, and then, well, then I tried to... Can we go in the cafe this way?
She goes, oh no, it's closed.
Yeah, everything was drenched.
Yeah, so that's why I ended up carrying a piece of cheesecake around with me all day long.
Moco-chan wouldn't carry it.
Yeah, but...
You might know because we kind of talked about it already, but we hadn't eaten it yet.
Well, we told you.
Eatin' it?
Eatin' it.
Eatin' it yet.
Which one is it?
Eatin' it or eatin' it?
Cheesecake.
That's what it is.
But actually, unfortunately, story continues, Ruffians!
Yeah.
Well, when we finally decided to eat it, we opened the box up, and there were two pieces of Ruffians!
Two.
Two pieces.
Even though we told her only one.
Yeah.
We made it very clear that we were gonna share.
Even though she suggested two.
Yeah.
And, it got worse.
I went to check the receipt.
Yeah, she charged us for two pieces.
Why?
What the heck?
Yeah.
Clearly, it's a very aggressive scam.
Cheesecake scam!
Yeah.
It was over 3,000 yen.
You know, which was already discounted.
Already discounted.
Yeah.
For two small pieces of rather normal tasting cheesecake.
It was yummy, but rather than cake, it tasted like fancy cheese.
Fancy cheese.
And I don't like cheese.
The bright side is that this is the first scam.
The first scam?
Oh, right!
It's the only scam that we get ourselves caught up in.
Only scam?
Only scam.
This was a scam with a rather delicious ending, too!
Right!
Only scam!
Yeah, only one, right?
Yeah.
Only cheesecake scam.
BAU BAU!
It has a happy end.
Please don't get scammed anymore!
We'll do our best!
I thought they were making scam Moco-chan though!
No promises.
I don't know.
Scam or... No... No...
We're not gonna make it a corner, Ruffians!
We won't talk to strangers, okay?
Yeah.
That was my mistake, hi.
She said she had cheesecake!
She was cute, she had a nice voice too.
BAU BAU.
Well, Ruffians.
On top of being a scoundrel.
We have something else we need to tell you.
And I know you hate to hear this, Ruffians, but it happened again.
Not a scam.
A different again.
Yeah, you know, we thought, you know, that we have experience now, that we should be good, but nope.
We had another misunderstanding.
You know, it's been a while.
A while for us.
A bit.
Right, and well.
You know, despite sharing this with you every episode.
Despite it being written at the top right of our screen.
Yeah.
Moco-chan.
Moco-chan messed up the hashtag in our tweet.
Tell the Ruffians what did you write!
I wrote hashtag...hashtag... FUWAMOCO Morning!
It should be FWMCMORNING.
Sorry Moco-chan, I'm confused.
I think there might be a misunderstanding.
What was that?
Hashtag!
Hashtag FWMCMORNING.
Moco-chan!
You're making more misunderstandings!
Hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Yes, you can tell it's very different.
One is correct!
One isn't!
Yeah, so Ruffians!
When using the hashtag, make sure you don't have a fuzzy brain like Moco-chan.
And get all confused and use the wrong one, okay?
No misunderstanding, okay?
Okay.
Okay!
Ruffians, what is the right hashtag?
This is the way you type, Moco-chan, right?
We have to confirm.
Yeah.
Uh-huh.
That's right, FWMCMORNING, but you've got the hashtag.
Yeah!
See, Moco-chan, you just have to dress like the Ruffians, right?
Well, we're always waiting for your thoughts and new submissions.
Especially, you know, it's the first FUWAMOCO Morning in a long time.
We'd especially love to hear about how FUWAMOCO Morning helps to start your day too.
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
It's the first FUWAMOCO Morning in a little while.
But...
It's that time of the week, Ruffians!
A new FUWAMOCO Morning, a new week, and a new challenge!
It's time for Moco-chan's natto challenge!
Moco-chan.
Some things don't change.
Yeah.
Well, Moco-chan's been doing her best to challenge herself to eat natto!
I have!
Yeah, and if you don't know what natto is, it's a very common breakfast food in Japan.
It's sort of pungent.
Yeah, it's fermented soybeans, and it's kind of sticky and slimy and stinky.
But it's really, really, really good for you.
Hi, I'm Moco-chan.
Yeah, you want to be able to eat it today.
I do!
I confirm, Moco-chan.
But last time, last time, Ruffians, Moco-chan did pretty well, right?
You beat a record.
Was it last time?
I think so.
You had eight, not two weeks.
I think I have been doing very well.
We've been doing this for much longer than eight weeks, but that's good.
So, this time too, Moco-chan... This time too, Moco-chan!
You're going to beat your best record, right?
No.
Yeah.
You're gonna conquer it, okay?
Conquer it just like a natto!
Yeah.
And then, you know... Hashi!
Moco-chan, I kinda feel like you're a little bit ready for this today, no?
I don't think so.
One moment, I'm gonna stir it up and make it nice and fluffy and slimy!
Like we talked about before, it's not the question of what don't we have yet, it's what do we have and...
Soy sauce is not one of those things.
Yeah.
We don't have soy sauce.
No shoyu.
But what we do have, because Moco-chan, you could have just this usual straight raw.
It smells different.
But, well, we do have the oroshi nama shoga, the ginger.
Ginger tube!
Grated ginger!
So, Moco-chan, you gonna have it with the ginger today?
Let's try it with a bit of the ginger.
Can you put a bit in there for me?
No, you could- Oh, you want me to do it?
Just a bit.
You have paws, you can do it!
Please!
Okay, Moco-chan, hold this.
Hold this.
How much should I put in?
Moco-chan said a bit, but I really like it.
Ginger?
Is there something wrong with that?
Stop, stop!
That looks like a good amount to me.
Is there?
Am I eating ginger?
Am I eating natto?
Wow!
Okay, Moco-chan.
Are you ready?
You probably stir it in.
No.
No?
Okay.
Dip it in the ginger.
Okay!
Moco-chan.
First, before you eat.
One second, there's lots of stickies.
First, let's say thank you to the farmers in Canada and the United States of America who were taught to make this.
I know Ruffians.
For some reason.
It's not Tochigi.
Yeah.
It's hard to find some delicious Tochigi natto for next time.
Right.
Yeah.
Different farmers now.
Different farmers, but this is the really, really good one.
I thought, ah, I want to eat really, really nice natto, so I got the really nice one.
It's so sticky.
That's why it's so nice.
Why is it so sticky?
And that's why it's from Canada and the United States of America.
Oh no, the ginger is sort of melting into it.
Why is it so sticky?
FUWAMOCO-chan!
Itadakimasu.
It's so sticky.
I dipped one bean.
I dipped the natto into the ginger.
Mocomoco-chan.
There is equal parts ginger, equal parts bean.
That's a lot of ginger.
Okay!
Itadakimasu!
Do I have pee?
No.
Pretty confident today.
No, no, no, no, don't, don't, the faces, don't.
It tastes spicy!
That's just the ginger, did you taste the natto?
It's spicy natto!
Spicy natto, you taste that, it's flavorful!
No, that's spicy natto.
No, try more, Moco-chan!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, that's spicy natto.
Can I have tea?
Let me try it.
It's spicy natto.
No.
I like that.
Spicy natto.
And the natto feels so good.
I'm like, awake!
Alive!
Maybe it's because of the ginger, but I'm not, no.
No, the best part of the natto is the natto.
I'm good.
Thank you.
It's good.
I'm looking forward to eating the natto, Wiz!
Moco-chan, you're not gonna get any more?
I eat one.
That's nowhere near close to your last record.
Are you serious about this?
It was still good.
Ruffians, we'll do our best to challenge ourselves to something new.
And remember Moco-chan's best attempt at eating the natto covered in ginger?
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Next we have our... Doggie of the Day!
Today's Doggie of the Day is... Peppa!
Peppa!
Cute!
She looks so comfy and ready to cuddle.
Right?
Lots of blankets.
Who's the blanket?
Who's Peppa?
It's hard to tell, but Peppa loves...
CCC.
She's a CC girl who loves camping, cuddles, and chasing cats.
I wanna chase after cats with Peppa!
Yeah, I wonder.
Peppa looks like she could be even faster than you, Moco-chan.
No.
Well, how does Peppa BAU BAU?
BAU BAI!
BAU BAU!
Like that.
Even when she wants to cuddle.
BAU BAU.
Just like that.
Yeah, well, I think we can all tell from this photo, but... Papa!
She's a blast to be around.
Yeah.
Yeah, she's even better than Paparoni.
Yeah, she can have my Paparoni.
Tell her to make sure that she gives the cats a lot of kisses when she chases after them.
For FUWAMOCO, kiss is dedicated for FUWAMOCO.
BAU BAU!
And next, Ruffians!
You've been on lots of walks, right?
And for today's I went on a walk, we have... De-den!
Aquarium!
Oh, you went to an aquarium!
That sounds like so much fun!
Penguins and alligators?
Aquariums have fish?
I guess they're kind of like friends with fish.
They eat the fish.
Friends?
Well, the penguins and the alligators were in separate enclosures.
I hope for their sakes.
Yeah, I'm a fish.
Yeah.
All separate.
FUWAMOCO!
It's been a long time since we went to an aquarium, but Moco-chan!
You really like the jellyfish, right?
I like jellyfish.
I like aquariums.
You know, I just feel like I could watch jellyfish forever.
They sort of remind me of living lavala.
I also like to eat them.
They're yummy.
Maybe we can go to the aquarium sometime soon.
We've never been to an aquarium in Japan before.
BAU BAU!
Next, we have our Question of the Day!
Today's question is... De-den!
How does one make a FUWAMOCO eat a pig?
What color do I choose?
Pink or blue?
Why for Ruffians?
Should I make two?
But I don't want to split them up.
It feels wrong.
BAU BAU.
Lots and lots of good questions.
Yeah, but eat the bags!
Ruffians, maybe there's some Ruffians.
I should eat the bags.
It's like a
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU
You know, Esme, you know, making it and designing it, I think it's up to you.
It's yours!
You know, you could do blue or pink or both or add some white or purple or black.
Yeah, do what you like best.
You could even use like fluffy and fuzzy materials too, like fur.
Yeah, lots of ideas.
Ribbons!
Yeah, ribbons too, you know, to show off you, your style.
Exactly.
What you want to do.
But we really hope that, you know, maybe soon we can release a bunch of cute merch and, you know, button badges soon.
And then, that way, you can decorate your lovely ito bags with it!
Yes!
You know, it's the armor.
Yeah, like armor.
It's kind of, it's like an ito bag that stretches your entire body.
It's awesome too!
You know, we can protect not just your smile, but
Your body too.
I wanna see you eat the arm okay, Ruffians!
Mix the bump.
Ready for battle.
BAU BAU!
Good luck with the eat-a-bag!
BAU BAU, thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions!
I know FUWAMOCO Morning is back, and we're so happy to be able to be there with you during your morning.
But, well, like we say, FUWAMOCO Morning is something we make together, so we're always looking forward to more doggy of the days, you know?
To see the kind of walks that you're going on, and where you're visiting.
I'm sure there's lots of questions.
There's been a lot going on.
And Pero Sightings too.
Right?
And also!
We have the FUWAMOCO Scoop too.
Maybe there's been some things that FUWAMOCO, you know, we've been busy deeming done.
Maybe there's some interesting news from us so far that we kinda missed.
Please let us know with the hashtag FWMCScoop.
And for all your other submissions, please use the hashtag FWMCMORNING!
BAU BAU!
That was definitely the silliest face you've made while sneezing, Moco-chan.
You didn't see anything, Ruffians!
Beautiful!
BAU BAU!
We have another stream coming up soon, right Moco-chan?
For our next stream we have De-den!
Tonight we're going to be reading your superchats.
Thank you so much, Ruffians.
Thank you for all your lovely superchats.
Thank you for the sneeze tags!
And thank you for all the messages while we were busy on our quests.
You know, it really gave us so much power to keep on going.
Yeah, you have no idea.
Thank you, Ruffians.
We're looking forward to chatting lots!
BAU BAU!
We're also gonna be playing Donkey Kong Country 2!
On the original SNES this time.
So we hope that you'll join us for a lot of silly times to come very soon.
And of course we're back to Advent Club too!
We're playing content warning!
And we have a Rock n' Rawr Party coming up too.
So we hope you'll join us this week for a bunch of fun!
Which is so exciting, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for the first FUWAMOCO Morning in quite a while!
Do you feel good to be back, Moco-chan?
Yeah!
Of course I'm happy!
Thank you, Ruffians.
We hope we can be a part of your morning regularly from here on out.
But, before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Hi!
Dog Chopper!
BAU BAU!
RYCJ!
Workmate!
BAU BAU!
Yuppie.
Ice core.
BAU BAU!
Rekusa.
Towel.
BAU BAU!
Aki.
Atoise Kitty.
BAU BAU!
Shabun.
Shirasui.
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
Hey, Ruff Friends!
Did you forget about me?
Well, I should better dog-dine hope not.
I'm the Great Perroccino!
But, I guess you can just call me Pero, right?
We're close after all.
Pals even, dare I say.
FUWAMOCO!
You know, they might have moved to Japan, but that doesn't mean I'm not around here and there.
You know me, I like to explore.
I see the whole world.
Maybe I'm not even too far from where you are.
Well, Ruffians, I know your true feelings.
I know you like me.
You want to spend more time together, right?
Go ahead.
Speak your heart's true desires.
After all, I'm the Great Perroccino.
I'm not some little pupper like the FUWAMOCO girl he is.
Well, I hope we can become even better, closer pals in the future.
Get used to this beautiful mug, you hear me?
See you later, Ruffians!
Ciao!